aujourd'hui je ne reçois pas un mais
trois invités je les ai rencontrés grâce
à l'association sister's et ils ont un
point commun ils sont différents
comme vous et comme moi en fait
puisqu'on est tous différents eux ils
viennent nous parler de leurs
particularités physiques et de la façon
dont ils vivent avec
sarah une trisomie 21 libre c'est-à-dire
qu'elle a reçue de chacun de ses parents
23 chromosomes comme tout le monde et un
chromosome 21 ans plus de l'un d'entre
eux marie est atteinte d'une ostéoporose
juvénile idiopathique c'est à dire que
saison sont déminéralisée donc très
fragile sans qu'on en connaisse lacoste
marie a aussi un diabète de type 1 c'est
à dire que son corps ne produit pas la
romagne chargé de faire baisser le taux
de sucre dans le sang qu'on appelle un
suivi médias une faux comédie des bras
c'est une malformation congénitale dans
laquelle les bras ne se développe pas
ses mains sont donc implanté directement
sur son trou alors est ce que tu peux
m'expliquer ce que c'est à
particularités physiques très amaigris
oui j'ai une fragilité osseuse qui fait
que je peux plus marcher
oui je l'espère un diabète de type 1
alors ma particularité ça s'appelle la
fauconnerie
donc c'est une maladie qui est très rare
qui n'existe plus malheureusement pour
eux et en fait c'est tout simplement une
malformation des membres à la naissance
donc ça peut être le haut du corps ça
peut être le bas du corps c'est très
variable
moi j'ai eu la chance que ce soit que
les bras qu'ils soient affectés moi
j'appelle ça une particularité physique
toi tu appelles ça comme un handicap
pour moi les saletés de cap c'est un peu
des maladies est ce que tu te souviens
du moment précis où tu as pris
conscience que tu avais quelque chose de
différent
le moment précis n'en chez que c'était
bas dans ma première rencontre avec les
autres enfants forcément début a même je
croyais que j'étais vraiment que je vais
été mieux de planètes ou un truc comme
ça donc je connaissais pas encore le
handicap les trucs et où et quand j'ai
vu qu'elle induit à l'école j'étais le
seul comme ça bah ça n'a pas fait un
choc puisque début quand tu es enfant
ben forcément tu es plus protégés par
les copains étaient plus protégés par
les parents et tous mais plus on grandit
sans plus on voit la différence c'est
tout et ouais c'est à ce moment là plus
on grandit sans que en étant enfant que
j'ai compris que j'étais pas comme les
autres bah j'en ai pas pris conscience
tout de suite déjà je suis tombé malade
j'avais 9 ans avant j'étais en parfaite
santé et
je
je sais plusieurs années après je me
suis rendu compte que j'avais une
différence surtout par rapport aux
autres on regarde les autres mais aussi
aux interactions je pense et puis aux
limitations qu'on rencontre
d'environnement tout bien plus
compliquée que ce soit l'accessibilité
mais aussi enfin par exemple à l'école
faut des aides particulières
ouais c'est toutes ces choses là qui ont
fait qu on se rend compte que c'est plus
compliqué que pour d'autres le truc
aujourd'hui dans ta vie de tous les
jours qui est le plus difficile par
rapport à ton handicap c'est quand
j'hésite jeunes qui ça me fait chier
quand même parce que non non sans blague
il ya un peu de tout le regard des
autres jeux pour ça c'est un truc qui me
gênait plus haut niveau de l'adolescence
et tout mais au bout d'un moment tu dis
bah tu es né comme tu es né et puis
voilà ça fait chier certains tant pis
pour eux c'est il ya des gens toujours
des gens qui se ferait chier
quelle que soit la différence d'une
personne qui soit sympa méchant message
ans
pour moi c'est un peu laissant un petit
mot que je peux en quoi c'est le trac
quand tu as compris que quelque chose de
différent je le ressenti comme ça a été
un peu compliqué moi j'ai mis du temps à
l'accepter
tu pourrais mettre un mot sur ce que tu
as ressenti je ne sais pas oui injustice
suspense c'est bizarre ce que je vais
dire mais être né handicapé je pense que
c'est une chance par rapport à quelqu'un
qui rencontre un handicap parce que moi
j'ai toujours appris à comme ça et
shekels et personne par exemple
connaissent un handicap au cours de leur
vie qui naissent valide entre guillemets
ou autre et qui perdent un peu je pense
que c'est plus difficile pour eux moi
j'ai grandi comme ça donc petit à petit
comme un enfant qui apprend plus en plus
à marcher à grandir et où j'ai toujours
d'après à me débrouiller comme ça au
début quand j'étais petit j'étais
vraiment autonomes j'ai toujours besoin
de quelqu'un je n'ai même pas écrire au
début et au moment du merci je reste sur
un étrange ballet je suis à 99% rendre
le nomme il tout va bien entre nous la
pratiquons aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton
rapport au regard des autres
c'est beaucoup moins compliqué qu au
début j'ai l'impression qu'on peut tout
de suite fermé si une personne va être
s'est ouverte et c'est lequel il va
méprisés ou ignorés et du coup bah je
vais plus à l'est vers les antilles qui
m'inspire quoi je me dis que peut-être
je vous détruite par rapport à ça parce
que ya pas forcément des mauvais regard
mais j'ai entre guillemets chez les
filles et 30 ans voilà c'est des gens
que je connais pas mais ça peut être
bien ça peut être mauvais mais le fait
de ne plus faire attention aux forces
forcément regarder lent mais je pense
que d'un côté c'est positif parce que on
se soucie plus un peu du paraître
par rapport aux gens veulent une partie
négative on y meurt peut-être des
occasions de rencontres une bonne
personne pas en disant ouais elle a un
regard mais c'est trop gentil donc c'est
bizarre c'était la pitié où c'était
autre chose donc ça se voit tout de
suite la façon de regarder déjà et en
face on parlait quand quelqu'un est gêné
ou parle pas trop moi je ne force pas
quoi mais il ya des gens qui sont très
ouverts et attend qu'on
on aborde le sujet tu abordes dessus de
tout handicap toi spontanément bas et
j'essaie de ne pas l'aborder plutôt de
faire comme si comme s'il n'était pas là
qui sauva la chose que l'on aborde en
premier tout vous me montrez moi avant
un handicap je pousse quand on travaille
dans la vie professionnelle et oups
c'est plus compliqué de me des liens
tout court pas forcément des liens
affectifs des amoureux même des liens
professionnels il ya un tous les genres
et bah je trouve ça dommage quoi puisque
au final il que les gens que je vois un
peu plus souvent que d'habitude qui
reste en tout cas dans mon entourage
mais après à moi aussi je fais un peu
petite mention soit je prends pas le
temps non plus forcément comme une
percée dans le fret la première blessure
si tu compris ça dépend les regarde dans
les yeux que je regarde dans les yeux
on regarde comme ça jamais eu mardi dans
ta vie à toi tu as envie d'être dans
leur vie à eux c'est ça oui tu as envie
d'avoir une vie comme comme les gens qui
sont en couple un couple
wallers et sa cachette et est ma vue ça
fait chier tu disais que tu avais une
période où c'était plus difficile au
niveau 2 au moment de l'adolescence
notamment comment est-ce que tu arrives
à identifier comment tu as appris à
vivre avec en grandissant je vais pas
mentir ça ma mère comme tous les gosses
je pense une fois arrivé à salage bas
j'y fais ma crise cimpor c'est une
histoire qui compte j'étais pas au bled
en vacances donc en tunisie et j'ai eu
la merveilleuse idée de me balader en
salopette sans tee shirt anti donc avec
les chicken que je les appelle à l'air
et la dgos que je connaissais pas de mon
quartier ouais c'est bizarre ce qui est
un être humain et ça m'a énervé je me
suis vexé et sur qui j'ai défilé ma
couleur sur sur ma famille je suis
rentré en dessous c'est pourquoi je suis
né comme ça
qu'est-ce que cela dit comme ça mais
elle m'a dit avec des mots un peu plus
gentil quand même et le fait qu'ils
aient masi ça je me suis dit bah ouais
qu'est ce que je vais faire
soit je pleure toute ma vie et je le dis
pourquoi c'est comme ça soit je vis ma
vie et puis mon histoire pas simplement
aujourd'hui au quotidien pour toi tous
domaines confondus c'est quoi le plus
difficile je pense c'est supprimer les
barrières ont semé s'était auto censure
que ce soit dans la vie professionnelle
même dans la vie sociale fin enfin se
dire que oui on peut voyager faire des
études qu'on veut travailler dans la
voix qu'on veut c'est ça le plus
difficile
déjà on a des limitations nous par
rapport à un autre handicap et et aussi
à toute la société enfin la société qui
en met plein d'eau de quoi avec plein de
problèmes d'accessibilité et ont parlé
at elle enfin on peut parler si telle
personne peut pas aller on veut parce
que les transports sont pas forcément
adaptées et ça ça rajoute aussi des
grosses la barrière
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir chez les femmes
fortes toi est ce que tu aurais un
conseil à donner aux gens qui vont
regarder la vidéo qui peut-être en une
particularité eux aussi qu'ils ont du
mal à accepter balle au conseil c'est
moi je suivrai un petit conseil s'est
pas forcément ignorer comment dire
ignorer l'attention des gens assez
compliqué ce que ce serait ce serait
bien vite s'habille comme on est quelle
que soit sa différence tout simplement
et tant qu'on s'accepte tant pis pour
ceux qui nous accepte pas y aura
toujours de façon des gens qui viennent
on sait pas bien ce que tu fais pas bien
ce n'était pas ainsi donc le principal
site voilà pas avoir honte de son
entraîneur
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup ça
une fois il s'est très bien battu a
tutoyé c'est ok